hey thanks miroslav and welcome
professor Blair I'm going to do just a
little background that extends what I
did a week ago big picture historical
sequencing and then I a sketch of the
clashing civilizations that Sam
Huntington the late Sam Huntington put
forward in his in the piece you read the
last time we looked at a long historical
sequence with the era of faith foundings
as a centerpiece and then the voyages of
discovery the Treaty of Westphalia and
the emergence of the Western nation
state system as a grid which largely
through the intermediary ilysm and then
independence from colonialism left its
imprint on every continent in the globe
on the globe and this thing turns orange
to black it's random the period of
Western colonial occupation becomes the
pivotal period during which cultures
most of all the metropolitan European
cultures come into contact with the rest
of the world often in a highly coercive
way sometimes in a constructive way but
at least as often in a destructive way
with the imposition of Western
institutions on cultural traditions and
on faith traditions which would in many
cases have preferred to have been left
alone
in the same period over the same long
sweep we have an essentially static
economic condition for the poorest 10%
of places on earth I let it turn up a
little in the last few hundred years
there are good economists who would say
it actually turns down that there's
actually a new book of a very
interesting new book called making
poverty Kona history which talks about
how there are hundreds of millions of
people whose material condition is
actually worse now than was the material
condition of similarly situated people
at any time in the past and I wouldn't
dispute that I mean I can't endorse it
or dispute it but it is arguable that
the bottom of the world economically is
actually lower now than it was in the
bad old Malthusian days further left on
the chart the what's pretty much
indisputable is that the richest ten
percent and one could as easily say
thirty percent of the world's places
have turned north in a very dramatic way
in the last 222 250 years and that the
consequent gap between top and bottom is
without doubt far greater today than it
ever was in human history the number of
really affluent people is way up but the
distance between them and those who have
not moved is arguably on in national
aggregates easily on the order of 50 to
1 and if you look at segments within
societies is arguably on the order of
five or ten thousand to one so you have
enormous inequality as one of the energy
producers in the world economy and one
of the producers quite often a very
negative energy and one of the let me
see what the number said okay five
minutes thank you i'll make that easily
the the 11 role that some of the faith
traditions have taken an can take is to
provide help and aid to those who are
least advantaged by capitalists global
development last time we also saw with
an animated diagram complex animated
diagram we saw the dynamics of this
world revolution and I pinned down the
demographic aspect of it which is
terrifically important this diagram is
something of a distraction because it's
a it looks like the back of a radio but
the the the gist is and this goes for
this is now true for something like 85
or 90 percent of the world that the
evolution of the world has been from
societies where there are very high
birth rates and very high death rates
and short lives in between on average to
a world in which there are low birth
rates low death rates and long lives in
between and when I say it applies to
eighty-five percent I mean not that
eighty-five percent have reached that
end point but at eighty-five percent are
at least in stages two and three
hurtling toward it and a few societies
have gone beyond it to the point where
births are
fewer than deaths and society is aging
and shrinking Japan for example but
that's a big background and I think very
possibly a big background to the faith
and globalization story that Professor
Blair and professors Blair and wolf will
bring us this is a crude periodization
of the last century before World War two
international relations and conflict was
understood principally as a balance of
power between the great great military
and economic economy nations from about
the Yalta treaty forward the cold war
became the dominant organizing frame and
if Sam Huntington is to be believed and
I think he is I think he's something
like sixty percent right the period that
followed the Cold War is one in which
culture faith identity race and an
overlay of class differences to find
economically and that overlay is often
unexpressed but terrifically important
it's an awful lot easier to become a
suicide bomber if you're substantive no
substantial material prospects in the
world this is one Geographic rendering
of Huntington's story the West shown in
what turns out on this diagram to be
brown the Orthodox also brown slightly
darker I guess Latin America to be what
it is sub-saharan Africa to be purple is
Lama Islamic and Hindu blocks are barely
differentiated in mustard color the
scenic block is visible as China the
Buddhist blocks and and Huntington
waffles on whether Buddhism is a
separate civilization and then you've
got Japan and he posits that there will
be two main kinds of conflicts involving
these civilizations or blocks one of
them will be core state versus Core
State so for example india vs china or
the United States versus an Islamic cord
State the other kind of conflict
deposits is what he calls fault line
conflict which is at the geographic
boundaries between these blocks smaller
states and non-state actors and
non-state actors become very important
actually may fight one another and may
engage in other forms of conflict and
final slide this is one attempt to
summarize the main lines of conflict
which Huntington believes believed since
he died recently will form the dominant
axes of conflict in the foreseeable
future it looks like Latin America is
blessed by this theory what's wrong with
Huntington is well I mean it's a it's a
ridiculously ambitious theory and times
up okay it's a ridiculously ambitious
theory and it's wrong in many parts
because there's a great deal of conflict
within civilizations right within 1
civilization
block all kinds of things happen that
Huntington gives no account of I'm
finished and floors yours